devant les tours de la mine trois femmes
essuient leurs larmes au milieu de nulle
part une cérémonie
aujourd'hui sept mineurs de fond sont
portés en terre victimes d'un coup de
grisou
nous sommes le 19 février le dombass
région de l'est de l'ukraine est en
deuil et ce même jour à 700 km de là
devant les caméras du monde entier
une répression sanglante et lancée
contre les insurgés de maidan à kiev
elle fera plus de 100 morts deux
tragédies deux visages de l'ukraine qui
s'opposent d'un côté une capitale qui
rêvent d'occident de l'autre cette
région minière tourner vers la russie et
qui a l'impression d'avoir été oubliés
[Musique]
trois mois plus tard c'est elle le
donbass qui fait l'actualité dans la
ville de donetsk
la capitale régionale des milliers
d'habitants défi le nouveau pouvoir issu
de la révolution de kiev
c'est là que nous avons rencontré
natalia elle est fille de mineur nous la
suivrons dans sa révolte
ce sont nos héros les mineurs du donbass
en compte
depuis toujours les mineurs meurent et
tout le monde s'en fiche et là qui a
fait c'est de nous imposer d'autres
héros énorme si tu y as n'avions pas
question une ukraine aujourd'hui
déchirée
la colère ne cesse de monter depuis le
début du printemps
[Musique]
armées ukrainiennes civile le face à
face ce temps un peu plus chaque jour
les villes d'udon basses sont en
ébullition des démons comme à terre ils
disent démocratie démocratie
moi je vois pas la couleur de la
démocratie c'est nous qui travaillons
pour l'ouest nous on les nourrit et eux
ils vont travailler à l'étranger
mais ce don de base qui travaillerait
pour toute la nation ukrainienne est
aussi frappé par la crise économique
[Musique]
carnet de route dans une région qui
peine à choisir entre deux pays
l'ukraine et la russie et entre deux
époques un passé soviétique et un futur
à inventer
[Musique]
nous commençons notre voyage à la mine
de severnaya où a eu lieu le coup de
grisou
les sept mineurs sont morts sous ses
cheminées noir c'est la mine la plus
récente de la ville
pourtant elle a ouvert en 1971 en pleine
époque soviétique
depuis comment cette industrie et à
travers elle la région du dombass at
elle vieillit exceptionnellement nous
avons obtenu l'autorisation de filmer à
l'intérieur de la mine
nous sommes escorté par le directeur qui
va nous faire une visite guidée en russe
même si le dombass et en ukraine peu
d'habitants parle d'ukrainiens
coli là c'est la salle fumeurs nous on
va plus loin
attendez je leur explique ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est la télé française
tout va bien voici les premières gueules
noires
cette mine en emploie 1200 le directeur
veut nous montrer les conditions de
sécurité
selon lui la mine est bien aux normes
mais nous découvrons une ukraine
figées dans le temps d'abord le guichet
où les mineurs prennent des jetons pas
de système informatique c'est le
décompte des bouts de métal qui permet
de vérifier que tout le monde est bien
remonté un peu plus loin la salle des
lampes
donnez moi une longue et un kit de
sauvetage
ici les mineurs prennent le matériel
qu'ils descendront dans les galeries
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le kit de
sauvetage voilà ce qu'on trouve à
l'intérieur
l'oxygène passe par ce tuyau dans cette
poche et là il ya lombo comme dans la
bouche qui permet de respirer comme ça
le mineur à 3 heures d'oxygène devant
lui pour à tomber sur le coup et après
trois heures qu'est ce qui se passe non
après trois heures salut les secours ne
sont pas arrivés
s'il arrive un équipement manifestement
désuet
nous nous approchons du coeur de la mine
demain que le milieu redescendre dans la
salle des ascenseurs la relève attend
son tour la saison hommes vont bientôt
s'enfoncer à près d'un kilomètre sous
terre
vous avez peur lors de quoi la part de
films et toi de temps en temps tu as
peur tu vois tu as ton travail et non
d'un autre
un premier ascenseur est chargé nous ne
pouvons pas les accompagner
selon la direction notre seul matériel
pourrait déclencher une explosion
les mines du dombass sont les plus
dangereuses d'europe
pas moins de cent morts chaque année
ces mineurs qui viennent de perdre sept
de leurs collègues sont visiblement
ébranlée
[Musique]
j'en connaissais c'était mon formateur
qui s'appelait sasha
quand je suis arrivé à la mine c'est lui
qui m'a formé et puis on est devenu amis
contexte où tu oses c'est dur
ces mines qui tue sont aussi celles qui
font vivre la région compte 250 mille
mineurs le charbon est essentiellement
vendue et consommée en ukraine
il pourrait être une alternative au gaz
importé de russie
mais aujourd'hui le secteur est en
déclin
cette mine sur dix appartiennent à
l'état et d'état est en crise
c'est tout a été construit dans les
années soixante dix depuis il ya
quelques travaux d'entretien mais il n'y
a pas eu de gros travaux de rénovation
car on n'a pas les moyens
vous n'avez pas les moyens à ce moment
le plus le charbon et rumba robin et
puis on peut ce très profond là ça coûte
trop cher et le travail manuel
notre entreprise n'est pas rentable on
vit aux crochets de l'état
les mines comme des puits sans fond
chaque année l'état leur verse 1
milliard d'euros une manière de
préserver l'emploi et la stabilité du
dombass
[Musique]
nous allons comprendre que la région est
encore sous perfusion comme autant de
l'époque soviétique
nous voici dans le village le plus
proche
il porte le nom de la mine c'est vers
naya il a été construit pour héberger
les travailleurs
[Musique]
alors
c'est ici que vivait la plupart des
victimes du coup de grisou comme nicolaï
qui était devenu gueules noires sur le
tard un voisin nous renseigne îles
habitées par là nicolas y avait une
famille oui il avait une femme et trois
enfants
ils vivent toujours là non brûlera
bonjour nous sommes des journalistes
français on aimerait vous parler
d'accord tatiana nous invite à rentrer
avec nikolay et les enfants il vivait à
5 dans cette petite maison qu'il
commençait tout juste à aménager
elle n'a pas encore eu le temps de
déballer tout les cartons je suis désolé
les enfants quasi le cadre car il se
battait pour l'embrasser il le serrer
très fort je n'ai pas eu le temps de le
refaire c'est pour ça que je les milla
ou nicolas y avait 38 ans il gagnait 300
euros par mois un peu plus que le
salaire moyen en ukraine cela faisait
seulement deux ans qu'il était mineur
après avoir enchaîné des petits boulots
précaires il s'était rendu à l'évidence
seule la mine pouvait lui garantir
l'avenir de sa famille avec la mine au
moins on savait qu'à chaque fin de mois
le salaire tombe et en plus les mineurs
peuvent partir à la retraite plus tôt et
le montant de la pension est plus
importante
nous on a trois enfants le petit à deux
ans et demi donc à notre âge ont
commencé à penser à la retraite pour
pouvoir aider les enfants au cimetière
elle peine à retrouver la tombe de son
mari
la dernière fois on n'était pas arrivé
par là elle n'a pas encore ses repères
la mine lui a pris son mari mais tatiana
n'a pas les moyens d'être rancunière à
son tour elle va les frapper à la porte
de ces verna ya désormais veuve de
mineur
elle a plus de chances d'être embauché
tatiana nous semble un peu à l'image de
ce peuple du dombass accroché à sa mère
nourricière même quand celle ci ne va
pas bien il y a longtemps que
l'industrie locale n'est plus cette
gloire de l'union soviétique qui
attirait les travailleurs des quatre
coins de lempire
comme les parents de valentyn dans les
années 60
valenti n'est d'origine russe il est
arrivé ici à l'âge de 11 ans pour suivre
son père après sa journée sous la terre
il prépare son potager à l'arrivée du
printemps
ça c'est de la gelée recouvert pour
qu'ils ne gèlent par m valenti les
mineurs depuis 37 ans il regrette la fin
d'une époque
à l'époque soviétique être mineure
c'était la classe il y avait une fierté
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est juste comme
ça ce travail n'a plus de prestige
valentyn est à la retraite mais il
continue de travailler sa pension de 250
euros par mois ne suffit pas comme
beaucoup d'habitants du nombre basse il
ressasse sa nostalgie sous l'urss
l'éducation et la médecine était
gratuite
la vie était beaucoup moins cher c'était
à la mine
c'était notre brigade c'était à l'époque
soviétique
en ce temps-là l'ukraine n'existait pas
elle n'était qu'un maillon de l' empire
sous l'urss
c'était beaucoup plus joyeux on allait
au restaurant il y avait une stabilité à
l'époque on pouvait se projeter dans
l'avenir
on savait ce qu'on l'avait ce qu'on
pouvait acheter
là on était parti en vacances en famille
ces mamans et papas on allait en crimée
pour les vacances
irina sa belle soeur est venue prendre
le thé avant de commencer son service de
nuit à la mine
tous les deux sont inquiets c'est l'état
qui paye leurs salaires mais depuis la
révolution de kiev
ils craignent que les nouvelles
autorités ne les met au chômage
on vivait tranquillement vivait bien
ils paient les salaires ils paient les
retraites
là ce mois ci ils paient encore mais
après on ne sait pas tout le monde crie
que les caisses sont vides depuis que
l'ukraine est indépendante
à chaque fois il ya des cataclysmes
déroule il parle d'élection d'élections
encore d'élections mais y'en a marre des
élections l'on veut du calme
la nuit est tombée irina par al amine
valentyn ne va pas tarder à se coucher
s'ils rejettent le nouveau pouvoir venus
de l'ouest
ils veulent que leur région reste
ukrainienne comme eux la plupart des
mineurs restent en retrait de la
contestation
car ils redoutent le chaos d'une
éventuelle guerre civile
à quelques kilomètres nous avons rendez
vous avec valérie il enchaîne des petits
boulots dans les mines de la région
à 40 ans il habite chez sa mère où il
mène une vie plus que modeste
[Musique]
valérie comment vivez vous on attend
tous la guerre et on sait pas ce qui va
se passer
[Musique]
les chars de l'armée ukrainienne sont à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres valérie
et sa mère suivent les événements en
regardant la télévision russe
comme beaucoup d'habitants du donbass
désormais ils sont résolument anti kiev
c'est l'horreur c'est horrible les
militaires ne sont pas des êtres humains
je ne comprends pas comment l'armée peut
tirer sur des innocents
je ne comprends pas tellement ça y est
est-ce qu'il faut des morts pour garder
le pouvoir même s'il redoute la guerre
valérie aimerait lui que sa région
devienne russe pourquoi la russie vit
normalement depuis 20 ans depuis la
chute de l'urss
pourquoi pas chez nous ça bizarre
pourquoi chez nous chaque fois qu'on a
un président c'est toujours un imbécile
ce serait mieux si c'était la russie ici
pourquoi là-bas l'ordre règne déjà il
n'y a pas la guerre chez nous ça fait 20
ans en fait même plus de vingt ans que
l'urss est tombée et nous on fait que
s'enfoncer toujours plus de plus en plus
c'est la merde tu vois valérie sait de
quoi il parle car ces dernières années
ce mineur a vu ses conditions de travail
se dégrader de manière spectaculaire
héritiers c'est ce que nous avons
compris il ya quelques semaines quand
nous l'avons rencontré valérie ne
travaille pas dans les mines public mais
dans des mines illégales
voilà voilà il vient de recevoir sa paye
ça fait 664 grives n'ya que j'ai reçu en
deux semaines
légré n'y a pas de dollars soit 50 euros
en 15 jours trois fois moins que dans
les mines légal devant cette épicerie où
les mineurs ont l'habitude de boire leur
vodka
valérie nous décrit un univers hors du
temps parfois il faut que je m'accroche
pour pâques tout s'écroule il ya un
passage de 85 cm de haut tu vois comme
ça on peut pas se tenir debout
il faut s'accroupir et ses salons et
dont l'eau s'est trompé dans la région
ils seraient plusieurs dizaines de
milliers comme valérie à extraire le
charbon dans les mines illégales
il accepte de nous en montrer une pas
l'une de celles où il travaille ce
serait trop risqué
nous allons au plus près
voici ce qu'on appelle un trou parmi les
mines sauvages les plus dangereuses ici
les ouvriers travaillent qu'avec des
moyens dérisoires
voici sorte de barks et baignoire ça
permet aux gens de descendre dans la
mine en bas on extrait le charbon on
charge la barque et aux montants et
quand c'est terminé on recommence
c'est dangereux parce que tout peut
s'écrouler à tout moment parce que le
câble peut lâcher c'est pas fortifiée on
n'a pas de cordes de sécurité
y'a rien tu peux mourir tout le monde
s'en fout il y à un mois
le câble qui tenait l'une de ses bêtes
noires s'est rompu un mineur est mort
victime symbole d'un monde sans limite
et sans droits celui que les habitants
du donbass craignent par dessus tout
car il associe les mines illégales à
l'apparition brutale de l'économie de
marché dans les années 90 après la chute
de l'urss et l'indépendance de l'ukraine
toute l'industrie s'effondre à commencer
par celle du charbon
la moitié des mines public du dombass
ferme les mines illégales vont prospérer
en récupérant le matériel désaffecté
c'est ce que nous allons comprendre avec
dennis un blogueur qui enquête sur ce
secteur très opaque
c'est là c'est là arrêtez vous
voici une coop en cas une mine sauvage c
rise entassés ont sans doute servi dans
une ancienne mine publique tout comme
ceux wagonnets
certaines mines d'état ont fermé mais il
restait le charbon est il resté aussi
les mineurs alors les mineurs se sont
mis à récolter eux mêmes le charbon au
début ils l'ont fait avec les moyens du
bord avec des pics qui démarre te il
travaillait les mineurs nous les
apercevons il ne semble pas apprécier
notre présence alors dennis va les
aborder
ce sont des journalistes français
personne ne le saura ici c'est de
l'anthracite on appelle ça de
l'anthracite c'est du bon charbon de
bonne qualité que devient ce charbon
comment fonctionne cette économie
parallèle dennis nous emmène vers un
entrepôt le charbon illégale ils
seraient mélangés à celui des mines
public
c'est dans ce genre d'endroit que le
charbon est blanchi la personne qui va
acheter le charbon ici va obtenir des
documents officiels ou comme si c'était
du charbon légal
on nous observe il faut mieux qu'on
parle car il risque d'appeler les
propriétaires ouï oui les gens là bas
en nous éloignant nous croisons une
voiture rouge qui intrigue dennis nous
abordons le chauffeur
[Musique]
vous travaillez ici non là bas c'est
bien une mine illégale
peut-être que oui peut-être que non j'en
sais rien moi je me balade 7 la voiture
repart mais un peu plus loin la revoilà
qui nous attend nous la trouverons cinq
fois sur notre route
selon dennis ce sont les mafias du
donbass qui tire les ficelles de ce
marché clandestin
valérie le mineur confirme il va même si
terrain non des mines illégales elles
sont sous le contrôle du fils de victor
ianoukovitch
c'est à lui comment vous savez ce que
tout le monde dit c'est son business sur
pâques boom victor ianoukovitch
l'ancien président renversé par la
révolution il est en fuite en russie
c'est un enfant du pays né à quelques
kilomètres de ses mines illégales
à travers son exemple nous allons
comprendre que les dirigeants de
l'ukraine étaient souvent des hommes à
la fortune suspecte
il y a quelques semaines nous avions
rencontré l'un de ses anciens proches au
siège de l'administration locale alors
sous haute surveillance après les
événements de kiev
nicolaï zagour ou hugo et conseiller
régional il est membre du parti de
l'ancien président après l'avoir soutenu
pendant des années ils l'accusent de
corruption est-ce que viktor
ianoukovitch est toujours votre leader
non pourquoi il n'a pas répondu à nos
espoirs
quand on voit ses intérêts personnels
comment lui et son entourage se sont
enrichis ça nous indigne il n'est plus
notre leader nous abordons la question
délicate des mines illégales
l'ancien proche du président va aller
droit au but
pourquoi personne ne s'est jamais battu
contre les mines illégales
comment se battre contre ça si c'est le
sommet du pouvoir qui est propriétaire
de tout ça on dirait que vous ne
comprenez pas c'est un état super
content
vous êtes en train de reconnaître que
c'est le pouvoir qui contrôlait tout ça
cognait je ne suis pas en train de le
reconnaître je vous le garantie à 100%
il n'y a que le pouvoir à ce niveau là
qu'ils pouvaient utiliser ce système
illégal a whole thing artaud il dotera
par le pouvoir
vous voulez dernier nous kovic 7 et
aujourd'hui c'est sûrement un autre
depuis cette interview la situation a
bien changé
nous sommes retournés dimanche 4 mai
devant le siège de l'administration
il est passé sous le contrôle des pro
russe qui l'occupent jour et nuit depuis
un mois ils ont dressé des barricades et
empêche quiconque surtout les
journalistes de pénétrer dans le
bâtiment
c'est ici qu'ils ont proclamé ce qu'ils
appellent la république populaire du
donbass
nous ne serons pas autorisé à parler au
responsable
seul natalia une militante acceptera de
nous accompagner
elle est fille de mineur et enseigne le
sport à l'université quand elle ne
travaille pas nathalie à passe tout son
temps sur les barricades
aujourd'hui elle rend hommage aux 40
militants pro russe mort la semaine
dernière à odessa c'est un mémorial pour
les victimes d'odessa qui ont été
brûlées vives dans la maison des
syndicats
on se souvient on les honore le donbass
va venger odessa pour natalia kiev a
franchi la ligne rouge en envoyant dans
sa région
les chars du pays si on cherche à se
protéger à protéger nos enfants et
protéger notre terre vous protéger de
qui de la jeune le fief et du fascisme
qui est venu sur notre terre des
nationalistes de l'ouest ils sont
arrivés au pouvoir
natalia aimerait que le donbass
rejoignent la russie pourtant il ya
quelques semaines
jamais elle n'aurait imaginé en arriver
là nous allons comprendre ce qui a été
pour elle un déclencheur
elle nous emmène à l'université de
médecine un cours de sport
[Musique]
ici les cours sont en russe comme la
plupart des habitants natalia par le
mâle ukrainien mais le nouveau pouvoir à
kiev a tenté d'interdire le russe comme
langue officielle de sa région
son identité a été touché au coeur son
sang n'a fait qu'un tour
il n'y en a guère se veut tout je me
suis senti humilié
ils m'ont humilié c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti on me dit tu dois faire ça mais
moi je ne dois rien du tout j'ai ma
propre langue que j'ai toujours parlé et
que je continue à parler alors cette loi
ne me plaît pas on ne peut pas traiter
les gens comme ça un sentiment
d'humiliation qui peut provoquer
l'embrasement devant le palais régional
occupée c'est la confusion des pro russe
en armes
habillés en militaires ont arrêté
plusieurs hommes qu'ils présentent comme
des pros kiev venus de l'ouest
il les emmène violemment à l'intérieur
du bâtiment
nous ne pourrons pas filmer la suite une
marche s'improvise les esprits
s'échauffent
[Musique]
la foule en colère part à l'assaut des
derniers bâtiments administratifs encore
sous contrôle de kiev lé drapeau
ukrainien sont décrochés déchiré puis
brûlé
[Musique]
pour terminer ce reportage nous
retrouvons valérie le mineur illégal il
nous emmène à un avant poste tenu par
les rebelles pro russe à la sortie de
son village une dizaine de jeunes hommes
pour l'essentiel cagoulés sont prêts à
donner la larme si l'armée ukrainienne
arrive et vous vous ferez quoi si
l'armée arrive moi je viendrai ici bien
sûr et je me battrai ici mais vous avez
des armes non on n'a pas d'armes
on a des battes de base-ball des bâtons
des pierres à la guerre on va la faire
avec les moyens du bord
[Musique]
quand nous l'avions rencontrée au début
du printemps valérie nous assurer qu'il
était pacifiste mais dans le donbass
le vent a brusquement tourné c'est un
vent d'est venus de moscou qui soufflent
désormais